はいっ
勉強ファイトしてほしいな勉強ファイターこんにちははじめ社長です皆さんはチーズと
いうものをご存知でしょうか
face 名称チーズ牛丼まあまあ柔道家さんには大抵あるメニューなんですけども
救助にチーズがかかってるやつがあるんですけども大好き屋に売られている3種の
チーズ牛丼3種類のチーズほっかかってる地域9チーズ級とかあるんですけどそれが
もうですねー
はいうまいんですけどもファン種類
変化なんで三者なんだろうという疑問を覚えまして
さあもう世界中の cheese 混ぜたらもっと美味しいチーズ牛丼
地球できるんじゃねっていうことで世界中に損ですちんなるべく集めてみました
うわっ
北垣編たくないせいか以前にそんな8種類のチーズ準備しました
年賀チーズってほど奥深くていろんな種類があるんですけども色々調べた結果なんか
チーズもある程度目がタイプに分類できるぽくてそのタイプに分類されたチーズの代表
作をここに集めた惨事になっています1個ずつ見ていきましょうまずはこちら
モッツァを屋町ナチュラルチーズの一種の
おっされがちですねナチュラルチーズの苦労譚どしたー微妙る見てフランスからという
のはコレ
シェイプれタイプというチーズで山の羊のミルクから作られるチーズですね組織が
もろく崩れやすいらしいです知ったこっちゃねえだからこんな変な認めしてるんだそれ
パルミジャーノレッジャーノっていうハードタイプのチーズですね
なんか勘坂坦言ったようにこれを機にカードで言ったらひとコマ
でこれらもうなんかすごいなトムと前に出てきそうゴーダチーズてやってですこれだけ
にハードというまぁ全然これでも人は殺す取れずハート分前にハード形になって感じで
これがみんなしてでしょうカマンベールチーズって言うんですね白カビか
それでこの上が白いの音白カビが乗ってるチームで柔らかくて味が濃厚という特徴が
ありますねこちら
プロセスチーズの6 p チーズ書道家長くなったんだかこうしたからプロセス中一番
音が我々の食べそうな気がする
これはなんかめっちゃ各県のゆがみたのこれは膨圧ドブルゴーニュ治療有効なんですね
ウォッシュタイプ
アルコールで洗ってんだこれ
妻
う夫妻ずっとな変な匂いがします香りが独特なクセがあるんですけど
クリーミーで柔らかいのが特徴らしいですね押しタイプでこれがもう見るからに青カビ
ですねどう見てまあおかげです
怖いですもう基本的には全種類の世界のチーズ集めましたこれを使ってチーズ企業の
今日は作ってみたいと思いますたぶん世界一美味しいチーズ牛丼にはなると思ってるん
ですけど
臭いのとかあるからちょっと何か
やな早速作っていきたいと思いますベア行こう
早速まず青カビから言ってこう青カビって作3位
ね
わー
さあ待ってくれあこんな入りすぎたかなぁ
うさ
こうめっちゃ濃厚だな子がまだおいしいは望結悪いけど味はおいしい
積んでるのね物議いきましょう次は epo はいきます
yeah
いた移動したうわぁでオナラのにおいがするわなんか過ぎ歴史を感じるのはこれで来
ない人見たねー
う
どれ今何か美味しいものを想像できないんだようーっ
ua 腐っとるやんけー
んだけどバッハ
ううううウォッシュタイプのチーズマジでやばいて良いが上向い合わずちょ
無理です上でペダル pg ていきましょうまあここらへんは本当に普段みんな食べ
てるチーズナンデ
チーズ牛丼もこれがベースなような気もしますねはめるチーズ白カビのチーズですね
うわぁわぁわあ
うわぁ独特な味だなんだ女かいいからから棒立ちですうわぁ見た目すげー
アニメに書いたようなチーズだわ
まあ匂いを全然そんなに
なんとなーくあったらこれぐらいでいい気がしますパルミジャーノ
勝手で包丁でなんとかってレベルですねプラダンとした日にあの
それが一番見た目が黒いなんか国になってしちゃうよねっと言います
うまえばおいしいチーズが多分裏ではバスケットシューズの裏の気がするわなんチーズ
てこう独特なにを用意ですかね世帯はモッツァレラチーズです主義がチーズですねも
美味しそうなんですよね
ってかいろんな種類の地図入りました案は知ってるんですよ
チーズて臭いはおりんですけど味は本当に美味しいんでこれ今が前進中[ __ ]して
フォローを
意図した最高のチーズて外のチーズの色の作り方正方ツールでかけませんが史上最強の
チーズ等ロールド引けばの牛丼
玉何でしょうにイーグル早速注意してきますゴンッ
あおっしゃってました go ああっ
ん
これアーマーグッズとしていることだとしたらエガー
メッツと外で切れなんか凄い凄いぞ通りとろりだ
明治のっぽい色
うわぁ
中途半端
もうちょっと食べます
世界中に散らばる全種類のチーズを集めて電子レンジで
て基調にチンしたら灯籠れとした不思議なチーズが完成しました
何とも言えない匂いが私たちを包み込みます橋でゆっくりとなぜてみるとあら不思議
討論ことろう
あのとろーりではない若干サバサバ感も伺いますがとろーりとしたチーズの完成です
このチーズを
うわちょっとちぇる作りすぎたーーーこれやばと思ったはずみ社長は
吹き矢のメガ級どうも準備巨大打球ドンに最高の地図を頭ローリと上からかけてみます
超なんとそこには今まで誰も見たことがない
史上最強のチギュ全種類のチーズをまとめた
最強ドチーズ牛道が完成したのです
[音楽]
さすがにうまそうこれは
なぜっ感やの匂いが島な側もご愛嬌ということでニオイは仕方ないこの風味も味も
すべて掛け合わさった最強のチーズというと前種のチーズ牛丼ですこれが史上最強の
チーズ魚を間違いましいただきます
まあでも本当になお店であるチーズ牛丼かもちゃんとありますねスペチーズが入って
おりますいただきます
うん
ん
うんうん
うまいえっうん甘い
本体ばえええうまいまあ
ううまぁちょっとまだレポートするには食べてないんだもうちょっと食べます
[音楽]
うまいうわぁ馬会は候補へ
うんああ
[音楽]
う
こういうなぜてメガ牛丼結構ありえないところで食っちゃったんですけど
美味しかったですチーズの濃さと曲の次元が違いすぎます
命がゲートに比べの全然チーズつくなかったかもですけども関係ないあんな大量の q
どんなでも殴り込みにいく
最強のハイターあんなたくさん中だったにも全く日にならないからチーム主張が
激しかったねあとかけすぎ明日にちょっと量が多かったから後半ちょっとっってなっ
ちゃったんですけど程よい
ようだったらマジでおいしい牛丼だったと思います俺が今まで食べたことがない牛丼の
世界に行けた気がした
書いたけど目指すで最高のチーズ牛丼の感性でさあ皆さんもぜひやってみてください
ブラわー
[音楽]
padi
んっ